in new york er und die gesamte usa
befinden sich in are der bisher
kritischen phase der pandemie mit einer
halben million erfassten infektionen und
trotzdem spricht der präsident von einer
baldigen wiedereröffnung des landes
zugeschaltet ist mir herbert bauernebel
aus new york herbert wie passt das
zusammen
der präsident guckt schon sehr weit nach
vorne hat man das gefühl die experten
hier in den usa sagen natürlich dass das
virus den zeitplan bestimmt für donald
trump gilt aber offensichtlich ein
anderer zeitplan ein politischer er
blickt bereits voraus zu den
präsidentschaftswahlen die anfang
november statt
hier in den usa und natürlich bemüht
sich dem antrag für eine wiederwahl für
weitere vier amtsjahre und er weiß ganz
genau dass das schwierig sein wird
sollte die wirtschaft komplett abstürzen
sollte amerika in einen wirtschaftlichen
ökonomischen krater stürzen eine mega
rezession
deshalb versucht der präsident die
wirtschaft jetzt wieder anzukurbeln so
schnell es geht es ist natürlich ein
gewaltiges risiko das er eingeht diese
entscheidung kann bedeuten
zwischen den unterschied zwischen leben
und tod für tausende zehntausende
menschen natürlich sollte das virus
wieder ausbrechen in einer zweiten welle
wenigstens ist sich dabei am besten
bewusst er hat gesagt das wird die
schwierigste entscheidung sein die ich
in meinem ganzen leben gemacht habe dann
würde diese entscheidung treffen wie es
weitergeht gibt es an speziellen
zeitpunkt über die agenturen lief vor
wenigen minuten dass die schulen erst im
september wohl wieder aufmachen
werden gibt es einen zeitplan für eine
entscheidung
auch diese nachricht habe ich persönlich
gerade gekommen meine beiden kinder
werden nicht mehr zur schule gehen in
diesem schuljahr erst wahrscheinlich
wieder im herbst was man hört aus dem
weißen haus ist dass der präsident hofft
dass es bereits am ersten mai oder
anfang mai losgehen könnte mit einer
graduellen inbetriebnahme der
amerikanischen wirtschaft man wird hier
wahrscheinlich verschiedener branchen
zuerst zu arbeiten lassen einen plan
soll hier ausgearbeitet werden es gibt
sogar eine neue task force die das
vorbereiten soll natürlich
realistischerweise erwarten die meisten
menschen das ist möglicherweise erst
anfang juni losgehen könnte mit der
öffnung der wirtschaft
lass uns noch ein wenig über new york
sprechen warum ist diese stadt warum ist
dieser bundesstaat so massiv getroffen
von diesem virus auch ein ganz
bestimmter stadtteil ist ja massiv
betroffen woher kommt das weiß man dass
wenn man das verstehen möchte hier new
york warum diese auf patrick so tödlich
so gewaltig wurde muss man sich
anschauen eine nachbarschaft in queens
die ausgerechnet noch dazu corona heißt
es ist ein immigranten und einwanderer
bezirk uns dort jetzt dass wir was am
schlimmsten zugeschlagen in new york
dass wir sagen es wäre das epizentrum
des epizentrums
wenn man dort herum marschiert in dieser
in dieser nachbarschaft sieht man
natürlich dass hier viele migranten
arbeiter einfache leute neben die jobs
haben die in denen sie nachgehen müssen
weil sie sonst nicht bezahlt werden und
deshalb sind sie auch weiter zur arbeit
gefahren wie das virus ausgebrochen ist
es gibt auch hier beschwerden in diesem
stadtteil dass man nicht gewarnt wurde
und dann hat sich das virus kann extrem
schnell verbreitet natürlich auch allein
bei den vereinen bei der fahrt in einem
u-bahnzug ist die ansteckungsgefahr
gewalt sind und dass man bemerkt hat wie
schnell dieses virus sich ausbreiten
weiß längst zu spät reagiert
dort in new york was uns trotzdem zum
ende dieser schalte vielleicht auf ein
wenig hoffnung schauen gibt es hoffnung
für die menschen in new york an diesem
osterwochenende gibt es dieses licht am
ende des tunnels zu diesem
osterwochenende ist es noch geschwänzt
ich stehe als ist eigentlich die letzten
tage und wochen war die new york gegeben
diesen großen feiertag natürlich in
ihren eigenen vier wänden wenige
menschen sind auf der straße als
hoffnungsschimmer muss man bezeichnen
dass sich die lage in den spitälern
langsam entspannt die zahl der
einlieferungen ist gesunken
eigentlich fast auf das niveau wie vor
der krise auch die zahl der patienten in
intensivstationen geht zurück man muss
natürlich sagen weil so viele leute auch
gestorben sind die auch seine bilanz in
new york city alleine ist jetzt 5800
tote aber selbst hinter mir sieht man
ein zeichen dass sich die lage langsam
entspannt dort stand vor zwei standen
vor zwei tagen noch zwei dieser
sattelschlepper anhänger wo tobte
gelagert werden und an diesem tag ist es
nur einer